маленька автократія маленька диктатура
ніколи не переможе велику диктатуру тому
що при зіткненні двох уламків радянської
системи переможе на жаль той який просто
більший натомість точно зможе перемогти
Росію точно зможе
перемогти оцей великий уламок радянської
імперії демократична країна демократична
Україна яка будуватиме цю свою роботу на
повазі до свого громадянина на чесній
серйозній розмові із своїм громадянином
і на досягнення ефективних механізмів
власне залучення громадянина до тих
задач які потрібні знаєте мобілізація
потрібна на військовим очевидно що
мобілізація потрібна всьому суспільству
тому що альтернативи не існує
альтернатива - це власне зникнення
держави